I'm Chris and I'm about to answer the internet.
Yay.
Would you rather be able to have sex with anyone you want or transport
anywhere in the world? Um, okay. Well then I guess, uh, I guess,
I guess I'd want to just snap the fingers and transport go wherever the I want.
I don't want to have sec. What am I going to get chlamydia again? Right?
You can have sex with anyone you want,
but they die immediately after who do you have sex with.
Myself.
So that's the way to commit suicide, baby. All these other hanging them. No,
that. Um, yeah. What do you have sex with? Anyone you want,
but they die immediately after we have sex with, Oh God, I don't know.
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Would you rather be twice your age or half your height? Oh my God,
definitely twice my age shortcuts. It's the worst. If you're short,
half my height, I'm going to say I'd be three feet tall. That'd be insane.
I don't want to do that. I mean, if I, I mean, well, I guess I'd be three feet.
Do I have the same size piece? That three feet tall. Y'all do that.
Then walk around with a nice dong. Cause twice my age.
I'm 34. I'd be I, yeah. Yeah. It'd be 68.
I'm not going to make it past 50. No, I got high cholesterol,
high blood pressure. No chance. So I'd be dead anyway. So I'll,
I'll do half my height, you know, you know, with the same size piece though,
at what age is it okay to let yourself go? Um,
I just think, uh, I mean, I, whenever you want, I mean, I've,
I've just been slowly letting my dude, first of all,
I have let myself go consistently. Since I got out of college,
like my nipples are just getting fatter and fatter and wider and wider.
I have full puff nipples. I swear to God I've legit.
I've legit and I don't mind. So I've been letting myself go, you know,
it's embarrassing sometimes when I hit a speed, but my juggle for a week,
but it's just what it is. So just let yourself go whenever you want. Be happy,
wherever the you want to say to yourself, just don't kill yourself, I guess.
But if you want to do it, I mean, what am I going to stop? You? It's like,
everybody wants to save everybody these days. It's not going to happen.
Just let people do what the they want. There's 9 billion abuts.
It's too much traffic.
Would you rather give up sex or porn for
one year? I could.
I would rather give up, um,
I'd say porn for it. I'd rather give a porn for you. I want to, I mean,
I w I want to, well, is this raw dog sex or condom sex?
That's a big raw DZ sex. Nah, you can't give a broad DZ sex.
Condom. Sex is a different thing. It's just, you know, you're just jerking off,
you know, you're just, yeah, you're having sex with a condom. Um,
not the woman or the guy, whatever your preference is. I don't care.
Transgender animals, whatever. I'll be happy. Right? Whoo Beyonce,
I guess I'd rather, I'd rather give up. Uh, I'd rather give a point.
I've got to do a point. I want to have sex. Yeah,
we're a DZ because Chrissy chlamydia in the house, when you're drunk,
is it better to get laid or have an ideal drunk meal?
Um, I guess what's it better to do get late when you're getting late?
Haven't when you, Hmm.
I guess have an ideal, uh, drunk meal. Cause you're gonna have, yeah,
because you're gonna have drunk sex. You're gonna have drunk sex. It's gonna,
you know, it's going to be kids disease. It's going to be a problem.
There's no chance when I'm drunk at 34 years old,
I can even get my Dick 10% erect. It's not going to, unless I got a blue chore,
Viagra, whoever the sponsor is, whatever, whatever, whatever erection pills,
sponsors, this show, that's what I take. And then we can get good to go.
Sometimes at this point. Now,
if I think I'm gonna have sex in three or four days, I just take a Viagra.
And I'm because it's just going to go away. I'm getting older.
I have high blood pressure, high cholesterol.
So I'm going to say ideal drunk meal. So yeah, absolutely.
I'm going to get lit and eat an empanada.
Shout out to my Puerto Rican PO people call me Papi. Um,
would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick or sit on a Dick and eat a
cake? Well,
the good news is any time I drink a white wine and have an anti-histamine and
I'm ready to suck Dick. So I've done both of these.
So it's just depends whose wedding.
I was at. Um.
I guess I'd rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick. Cause you know,
get a little sugar in the, um, or sit on a Dick and eat a cake. You know what?
It depends how big the Dick is. You know,
I don't need my appendix removed again. You know what I mean?
So I don't want to Wang.
It depends if the Dick is five or less, I'll sit on a Dick and eat a cake.
I love sweets. I'm Chrissy, maybe my special size,
38 ways your kid loves to sugar. So if you're five or less,
I'll sit on the Dick and eat the cake. If you're five or more,
I'll sit in the cake and eat the Dick. Why not? You get. Well, you know,
everybody gets one to the uvula. It doesn't matter. That's the thing.
It just doesn't matter. You put a in your mouth. It's like, whatever.
Would you rather be bald by age 20 or five?
Three with a full head of hair. Wow. Lord Marquardt. Um,
bald by age 20 is rough. That's rough.
I got a few of my friends Debo or a few of my friends who do that ball by it's
20 or five, three with a full head of hair.
You know what I think I'd rather just be bald by age 20. Yeah.
Because I get you to, you know, you can just have a shaved head, whatever. Yeah.
You know, heres whatever five,
two with a full head of hair is kind of a funny look though,
just like a action figure, walking around. I want an idiot.
Would you rather be hooking up with a girl and prematurely calming your pants
and she finds out or start crying in the middle of sex again? I've done both.
So first time I ever had sex, I swear to God.
I cried after cause there's emotional tipping. And I swear to God,
the girl punched me in the chest.
I've I've told the girl Latisha punched me right in the chest.
Cause I couldn't get my Dick up. It's I swear to God, no black girl, great girl.
Um, but hit me right in it. Right in the sternum.
And then I just couldn't get it up. So I started crying.
It was a whole emotional, I swear to God, I was emotional thing.
It was emotional thing. It was 2001. You know, it was right after nine 11.
It was a big problem. I swear to God. So it's like I was crying.
It was a whole thing. Would you,
or would you rather be hooking up with a girl and prematurely come in
your pants and she finds out?
Yeah. I mean.
I mean I'm always pre calming, you know what I mean?
I'm Chrissy pre-conference absolutely. Dude, I got a steady drip.
It's not always chlamydia folks. Um,
sometimes you just a little splurged up.
You know? Um, nah. Yeah.
I'd rather start, I'd start crying. The Middlesex I've been there, done that.
Never forget
you get to have sex with the girl of your dreams,
but they hold a press conference after rating your sexual performance.
Do you do it? The thing is with me,
I'm going to say no,
because it's the thing is I think I'm okay in bed. I just,
I can't go down on a girl. Anytime I go down on a girl,
I get a sore throat and they're always mad at me. So I don't want to,
they would mention that, but he didn't eat me out. It's like, well,
you know what I mean? Your is not made of penicillin.
I can't be out three to five days with strap. Again.
I just have a weak immune system. So I would have to like, you know what I mean?
I would do it. If I could rebuttal the press comes and be like,
it's not that I didn't want you out. It's just, I, you know what I mean?
I don't have antibiotics right now, but it is the girl of my dreams.
So you're saying the girl of my dreams, you get to have sex with the girl,
your dreams, but they hold a press comp. Yeah. I'm going to say no,
I'm going to say no, I can't do it. Would you rather yourself?
Every time you have an orgasm or get a random every time you talk to a dude
while I've been full stiff since I've been in here. So do ever since yeah.
Your hair. Yeah, absolutely KFC sweater. I'm through the roof.
It's just a full woman sweater. But I love it, dude. I feel like, yeah.
Would you rather yourself?
Every time you have an orgasm or get a random every time you talk to a dude?
I mean, yeah, I'm just a guy. I just, I pop wood, you know,
I just pop it. So I get bonus talking to dudes all the time.
It's just like a symptom of me being me. The thing is I have sex with women.
I fall in love with guys. So anytime there's like adult conversation,
if someone wants to talk to me about like Yankee games or something,
I'm getting trumped up. So, but would you rather yourself?
Every time you have an orgasm? I don't know. I think I'll just,
I'll take random every time you talk to a dude because
you're yourself. I mean, yeah. I just, yeah, it's a catastrophe.
Gotta wear a diaper. You know, I don't want to do that. Starting today.
If you get $10 on, sorry, starting today. If you get Oh, 10,000,
what is it starting today? If you get $10,000 a day for every day, you don't.
How many days could you go without jerking off Jesus Christ.
So I'm getting 10 GS a day for everyday. I don't jerk off. Oh my God.
I'll probably get 20 GS and that's it. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
what am I going to do? I mean, how much money do you really need? You know,
how much bigger do you want your house to be? I'm good with 20 GS. I'll,
I'll gamble it on. The giants will lose it all.
Just be like my dad live on Staten Island and a one bedroom, whatever. Well,
w w would you rather have a good hand job from your grandmother or a bad hand
job from a grandmother? So it's the grandmother's one. Okay. I wasn't,
I didn't know if it was like,
would you rather have a good handout for your grandfather or bandage off your
grandmother? Because that changes the question.
So it's bolted to the grandma a good hand. You are a bad hand. I mean,
I guess I'm going to want to have a good hand job. It's my grandma. You know,
why don't you probably got soft hands, blow away, different story.
Cause like with teeth or without teeth, if she'd taken her dentures out,
because then it's like, you know, I know it's my grandma, but you know,
it's soft in there.
Your mom and girlfriend switched bodies only way to get them
back to normal is to bang. One of them. Who do you have sex with?
To think about my mom with my girlfriends,
Puerto Rican is the funniest thing I've ever thought of what to think about my
mom having a tattoo on her tit. Um, it's hilarious. Um,
but who do I bang out?
[Inaudible].
I guess I, um, I guess I bang,
I bang my girl with my mom's body. Cause that's just like, that's just like,
yeah. I w I would do that cause my mom, you know,
because my mom really non,
I dunno now I can't bang anything. It looks like my.
Yeah.
Your mom and girlfriend switched bodies.
The only way to get them back to normal is you have to bang one of them.
Who do you have sex with? So either way, I'm kind of having sex with my mom.
I would rather close my eyes. My mom went to an Ivy league school.
So you know what I'm changing. Yeah, absolutely. I don't know.
It just had nice smart brain. I'd like to bang that out. You know,
this is a tough, this is a hard question.
Every time.
Well, she knows that we had sex.
It's just that you have to suffer that you're upset.
Yeah, my mom, yeah. Having sex on my mom's body. Yeah. At this point, yeah.
She's 66. It's like, yeah. It's like having sex with my dad's body.
It's the same body at this point, you know, but they're aware of it.
They're they're cool. I guess I'd still have sex. I'd have sex with my, uh,
I'd have sex with my girlfriend's brain in my mom's body. Yeah. Why not? it.
Yeah. Bang it out a little bit. Yeah. That'd be fine. I'm a margarita. Go to,
you know, learners. I don't know. It was good. All right. Yeah.
All right. Thanks buddy. Appreciate it, man. Thank you.